welcome to Wholesome roots today I'm
going to show you how to transplant
Tomatoes looking
good anybody who has followed me for any
amount of time knows that my tomato
plants get completely buried the whole
plant all the way up to the top growth
it's what I consider the absolute best
method for tomato planting you get tons
of root development and really healthy
plants this way so first thing you want
to choose healthy plants I have two that
are
growing oops I have two that are growing
I have two that are growing together
that I'm going to pull apart gently
teasing The Roots apart so whether you
start your transplants yourself from
seed or you buy them from a local Source
just choose the healthiest ones you see
then you're going to dig a nice deep
hole the whole height of the plant in a
wonderful compost soil well- drained
full sun that means you need 6 to eight
hours of Sun for these plants sometimes
I even will water inside the hole to get
it moist deep down inside before I
transplant then you put your plant all
the way to the bottom of the hole
leaving just the top of the plant above
the soil line so my soil is going to
come all the way up on this plant and
it's going to lead to root development
all along the
stem tomato plants root very easily on
the
stem now you can pinch the lower leaves
off or leave them on I didn't have but
one on there so it got buried it won't
hurt anything and that's that water it
in well right after planting
and keep an eye on it over the next
couple of days in water if you see any
wilting this is the most easy and simple
way of planting tomatoes that I have
found and I really have found it so easy
that I almost cringe when I see people
planting long leggy tomato plants all
above ground cuz I think about all those
roots you could have had so make sure
you don't miss out on your chance to
have lots of roots to help support the
plant to get the most nutrients from
your compost rich soil and the biggest
and most beautiful tomatoes but you do
have to give careful consideration to
how you support them during that growth
cuz tomato plants can get taller than me
and I have a great video that teaches
you all about different trellising
methods that are affordable and easy to
use check it out make sure you check out
our tomato playlist because one of the
things I've always been called is the
Tomato Queen ever since I was a young
girl I was always the one who grew the
biggest and best tomatoes thank you for
watching we'll see you next time on
wholesome roots
[Music]